muchos piensan que la riqueza de suiza
se debe únicamente a su condición de
paraíso fiscal pero lo cierto es que
otros países como panamá chipre o
incluso la república africana de liberia
también ofrecen condiciones fiscales muy
favorables para las empresas y sin
embargo son países pobres o de renta
media-baja suiza es uno de los cinco
países más ricos del planeta y todo esto
sin comprometer los derechos humanos ni
la democracia al contrario el país
helvético es uno de los lugares más
igualitarios del planeta cerca de otros
sitios como noruega o dinamarca
el sistema democrático no sólo permite y
garantiza que los ciudadanos voten cada
cuatro años sino que además les permite
participar en casi todas las decisiones
políticas cada cuatro meses
personalmente creo que suiza tiene uno
de los mejores sistemas políticos del
mundo y esa es la auténtica razón por la
cual son tan ricos creo que de verdad
todos los países deberíamos tenerles
como un modelo a seguir hoy os voy a
explicar por qué
razón número 1 descentralización lo
primero que tenemos que saber es que
suiza es una confederación es decir está
dividida en 26 regiones lo que llaman
cantones que son totalmente
independientes entre sí lo único que
tienen en común es el ejército la moneda
la política exterior y la constitución
para todo lo demás son prácticamente
estados soberanos para que os hagáis una
idea con un sueldo de seis mil francos
suizos si viviéramos en el cantón de
jura estaríamos pagando un irpf es decir
un impuesto sobre nuestro sueldo de un
más o menos un 14% mientras que si
viviéramos en el cantón de zug que es
uno de los cantones con los impuestos
más bajos pagaríamos solamente un 4%
menos de la tercera parte
otro ejemplo es que en ginebra todos los
comercios absolutamente todos tienen que
cerrar a partir de las 6 de la tarde
mientras que en turís tienen libertad de
horarios
gracias a esta descentralización todos
los cantones pueden ajustar sus leyes a
las peculiaridades del territorio y de
la sociedad que tienen y lo que es más
importante pueden competir o sacar las
mejores legislaciones esto explicaría
también por qué en suiza en general
tienen unos impuestos tan bajos porque
claro si tú vives en un cantón y de
repente te suben mucho los impuestos
siempre te puedes mudar al cantón de al
lado y es mucho más sencillo que emigrar
a otro país
razón número 2 suiza no tiene presidente
todos los países del mundo tienen un
presidente o un jefe de estado verdad
bueno pues suiza es la excepción ojo
esto no significa que los suizos vivan
en una especie de anarquía ellos votan a
un parlamento nacional que a su vez
elige a siete miembros de lo que podría
ser algo así como un consejo de
ministros que ellos llaman el consejo
federal
de esas siete personas hay una que es la
encargada de representar al país en el
exterior y ese es el presidente de suiza
pero realmente no tiene ningún poder
adicional sobre el resto de los miembros
del consejo federal de hecho cada año
van rotando fijaros en el cambio de
mentalidad en cualquier otro país el
presidente del gobierno o el primer
ministro es una figura muy importante
sin embargo en suiza es una figura
prácticamente simbólica porque casi
todas las decisiones se toman de forma
colegiada
razón número 3 democracia directa pero
sin duda alguna lo más conocido del
sistema político suizo es la democracia
directa casi todas las decisiones
importantes de la política suiza se
toman mediante referéndum
algunos son a nivel nacional y otros son
a nivel cantonal para conseguir que una
ley se someta a referéndum
basta con que cualquier ciudadano
consiga recoger 50.000 firmas y si esa
ley implica una modificación de la
constitución entonces tiene que recoger
100.000 firmas
es verdad que en otros países también se
permite que un ciudadano proponga una
votación o un referéndum en españa sin
ir más lejos bastan 50.000 firmas para
proponer una iniciativa legislativa
popular sin embargo ésta no puede
afectar la constitución mientras que en
suizas
así es como en este país se celebran
referéndum de forma habitual
concretamente la gente se junta cuatro
veces al año para votar todos los
referéndums que se han ido proponiendo
en los últimos cuatro meses por ejemplo
este mes de junio se reunieron para
votar si querían una renta básica
universal o no pero en esa misma
elección también aprovecharon para votar
si querían un cambio en la ley de
reproducción asistida otra ley también
otro reglamento para regular el
transporte público a nivel federal y una
enmienda a la ley de acogida de
refugiados y no os creáis que estos
referéndums tienen una participación
sorprendentemente alta concretamente en
esta última votación votaron más del 60
por ciento de la población
número 4 libre mercado muchos pensarían
que en una democracia tan directa es muy
normal que surja un líder populista que
quiera destruir el capitalismo verdad
pues resulta que suiza es uno de los
iconos del libre mercado no olvidemos
que es un país que está aislado entre
montañas y que apenas tiene tierra
cultivable con lo cual les conviene
firmar acuerdos de libre comercio con
prácticamente todos los países pero mis
queridos amigos liberales y libertarios
que sé que muchos estáis viendo este
vídeo contener vuestra alegría por un
momento porque si bien es cierto que
suiza es un país muy abierto al libre
comercio no lo es mucho más que la unión
europea
los suizos también subvencionan a su
sector primario y tienen una ley muy
parecida a la pac europea y no sólo eso
es que también participan en los
bloqueos y sanciones comerciales a
países como rusia o irán así que la
única diferencia real en lo que a libre
comercio se refiere entre suiza y la
unión europea es que los suizos llevan
comerciando libremente desde 1874
mientras que el resto de países europeos
llevamos abriéndonos al mercado
internacional solamente unas poquitas
décadas bueno en realidad también hay
otra diferencia que ahora mismo vamos a
ver
razón número 5 neutralidad efectivamente
suiza es uno de los pocos países
neutrales del mundo esto significa que
nunca por principio intervienen en
ningún conflicto armado ni siquiera la
segunda guerra mundial pese a que buena
parte de la población estaba en contra
de hitler gracias a esto suiza no ha
tenido que gastar dinero en recuperarse
mientras que el resto de países europeos
se gastaron una fortuna primero en
matarse unos a otros y luego en
reconstruir todos los destrozos de la
guerra suiza ha podido aprovechar todos
esos recursos para mejorar su estilo de
vida y es que en contra de lo que dice
mucha gente el mayor enemigo de una
economía es la guerra
pero ojo todo esto no significa que
suiza no tenga ejército la diferencia es
que sus fuerzas armadas nunca irán a
otro país a intervenir en conflictos
militares ajenos están únicamente para
defenderse de ataques del exterior y
aquí es donde viene una de las pocas
cosas que no me gusta un pelo de este
país todos los ciudadanos helvéticos
están obligados a hacer el servicio
militar desde que llegan a la mayoría de
edad hasta que cumplen los 30 años
tienen que pasar un mes todos los años
en el ejército
por supuesto que suiza no es el único
país con servicio militar obligatorio
hay otros lugares que también lo tienen
como noruega o israel sin embargo a mí
me parece que es una violación de los
derechos más fundamentales porque nadie
debería poder de obligar a trabajar en
algo en lo que tú no quieres estar ni en
el ejército ni en la función pública ni
en ninguna empresa tiene que ser una
decisión tuya pero en fin algo malo
tendrían que tener en suiza- no
razón número 6 impuestos bajos
finalmente otro aspecto archiconocido de
la política suiza son sus impuestos es
verdad que hay muchas diferencias entre
un cantón y otro pero en general en todo
el país los impuestos son muy bajos y
además las leyes para montar nuevos
negocios son muy sencillas y se pueden
ver muy fácil a través de internet de
hecho el gobierno suizo es también un
pionero en la transparencia y si esto ha
permitido que muchas empresas
extranjeras se instalen en suiza pero
también hay fomentado la creación de un
montón de empresas originarias de este
país y si vale la banca suiza tiene un
peso muy importante en la economía pero
también hay muchos otros sectores que no
nos paramos a pensar pero están ahí hay
un sector farmacéutico enorme con
empresas tan grandes como novartis o
hoffman la roche por no hablar de los
relojes el turismo las empresas de
maquinaria de precisión en general estoy
seguro de que todos si os paráis a
pensar encontrareis alguna empresa suiza
que os suene y todo esto en un país con
menos población que méxico df
en fin que como os decimos siempre en
visual político lo que hace rico a un
país no son sus recursos naturales ni su
suerte sino sus instituciones y su
sistema político y en ese caso parece
que a los suizos no les ha ido nada en
cualquier caso esta es mi opinión
vosotros qué pensáis creéis que nuestro
país podría mejorar si imitar a un
poquitín al sistema suizo podéis
escribirme vuestras ideas en los
comentarios de este vídeo si alguien
quiere profundizar más en este tema os
he dejado varios links en la descripción
si os ha gustado el vídeo darle al like
y suscribiros si no lo habéis hecho
todavía un abrazo y hasta pronto